kanye's been in wyoming and he's been
posting a lot of things
on social media so that is a little bit
frustrating
kim kardashian and kanye west's marital
troubles are starting to play out
on keeping up with the kardashians you
just have to
kind of separate yourself from like
what's going on at home
and what's going on on the internet on
thursday's episode of the show's
20th and final season the reality star
is dealing with
tensions in her marriage but tries to
keep the most personal details
off camera it's no secret that everyone
sees things in the media
about my life with kanye but i've always
been really respectful and not talking
about
issues that kanye and i have i mean you
guys clearly see them on twitter
so i'm still going to choose to not
really talk about it here
we have different views sometimes that's
not stuff
we put on social media i'm not going to
you know just start
tweeting what my thoughts are then
during a family lunch
kim is seen outside talking on the phone
about flying out to wyoming to see her
husband
following a slew of since-deleted tweets
calling out her
and her family i'm happy to come i mean
i can get on a plane
tonight when i talk to him he says no
he might say things that might get
misinterpreted
and people don't see the context behind
it but i always know his heart
i don't know i just feel like she's
struggling a bit
with all this stuff going on i don't
know how she's dealing with the stress
of it all you know that's what i worry
about she's always like the calm in the
storm
i think she's got a lot on her plate
she's got a lot going on with law school
and
everything else the kids everything she
can't possibly navigate this on her own
last july kanye took to twitter to fire
off a series of since-deleted tweets
aimed at kim and
chris after announcing his plans to run
for president
in the 2020 election a source told et
at the time that kim was quote
completely devastated by the public
messages and was hoping to get her
husband help
in the past the rapper has been open
about his struggles with bipolar
disorder
a source told et at the time quote kim
has always been public about
everything in her life but with kanye
and him being bipolar
she has always respected to keep that
more private
and within the family oh my god that kim
would make the best first lady
i was like you know i mean i don't want
to talk about it on camera so
got it i just don't want to talk about
kanye or anything
i've seen him go through a lot and he's
just the most
genuine person to lift kim's spirits
courtney and chloe hosted a girls night
at the family's malibu rental home
despite trying to avoid it the topic of
kanye did come up
at least once how are you and kanye now
moseying on along what i had to talk
with him
he called me the other morning i meant
to tell you about me
he said it would be nice to be able to
like say things i said yeah say what you
want to say
maybe it'll start people thinking a
certain way or getting a thought in
their head but did you
have to say those tweets publicly and he
said no you're right
i shouldn't say i shouldn't say that
publicly and while the kkw beauty
founder didn't go into detail on camera
she did say that she knew it would all
be okay
my life with kanye i got this like i'm
dealing with it
on my own like it's gonna be okay and i
love like
coming over to malibu and escaping and
being just as
in the moment as possible my sisters
know that and i love them for it
kim officially filed for divorce on
february 19th
after six years of marriage a source
told et
that they are asking for joint legal and
physical custody of their four children
north saint chicago and psalm and are
committed to co-parenting together